they may need to sit down for this next
item or perhaps more aptly pour yourself
a glass of vino because world wine
production is actually set to fall to
its lowest level in more than 50 years
but I'm joined now to discuss this with
Peter gladwyn he's the proprietor of
boutique wine maker not borne vineyards
and the Deputy Chair of English wine
produces a very warm welcome to you this
evening what's going on well what's
going on globally is not necessarily
happening in this country the weather is
affecting wine across the world the
world process at the beginning of this
year across Europe which thought made us
all think it would be the most terrible
season but actually good old Britain has
recovered
okay so Britain's done okay but Italy
Spain France have all seen really poor
productivity this year other wine
producers though because when I think of
where we buy our wine from it comes from
all over the world surely they make up
for any losses that we've suffered here
in Europe I thinking Argentina Australia
mi the South America they had a better
year this year but they were devastated
by weather in 2016
Australia is actually up America about
the same but Europe is still a huge wine
producing and part of the world
France and a number one slot now Italy
number one then France then Spain
England tiny industry but we are growing
steadily and this year we've got some
really good fruit out there that's very
encouraging given that we're potentially
facing the worst level since 1961 what
does that mean in terms of our consumers
people going to buy wine are there going
to have a run on their favorite vino I
don't think it'll quite come to that
there has been a wine surplus and bear
in mind people drink wine every year of
different vintages different years it
needs several years in a row to create a
real shortage some of the great wine
producing areas of France are definitely
down but actually here in Britain we're
producing wonderful sparkling wine which
is competing with champagne
so this could be a good thing and just
finally what does your wine taste like
give us a little sample it's that time
of day when people are cracking open a
boy should have brought us
you should have sorry I was short notice
the great thing about English sparkling
wine is that it is full of fruit
freshness where we're an island we have
coastal breezes so it has its individual
characteristic and and I promise you
truly delicious you haven't tried it you
must do them know what Peter glad when I
shall take you up on that thank you very
much for coming in and reassuring us
that there won't be too short of wine
anytime soon thanks very much indeed